Speaker 1: We're not going to spend a ton of
time on this because we've just not we don't
have that much time left on today's show. It's
been so packed. But I do encourage folks to check
out the arrest warrant and the indictment of
George Anthony Duvall there. Santos, including
the full list of charges. There's funny stuff in
it and there's interesting stuff in it. I'm going
to put up just the first page of the arrest
warrant. I don't know why I find this so damn
funny. I don't know if it's a version of satire
of some kind or if it's just totally standard.
The arrest warrant lists him as George
Anthony Devil there Santos, a.k.a., in quotes,
George Santos. I couldn't stop laughing when I
saw this because it it may well be that this has
nothing to do with the fact that he has changed
his public name over time without I'm not saying
he legally changed his name just the way he has
publicly stated who he is. Videos where he says,
I'm Anthony Davis, older and I run a pro-Trump
group. I'm George Santos, I'm George Anthony,
and all these different things. This may just be
a completely standard thing that has no bearing
on on that George Anthony Devil there, Santos,
a.k.a. George Santos, as if he's been living
under a false name for some period of time.
Absolutely love it. But more importantly,
the indictment and the arrest warrant describe
the offenses which include wire fraud,
money laundering, theft of public moneys and false
statements. And it lists the specific laws that
that he is accused of having broken. And there
are a number of articles you can look at which
go into more detail. It's actually seven counts
of wire fraud, three counts of money laundering,
one count of a theft of public funds, and then two
counts of lying to the House of Representatives
on financial forms. That's the that's the false
statements element of this. As the article says,
for missing wire fraud is the most serious charge
and carries a penalty up to 20 years in prison.
And as is often the case in these situations,
if we get to a guilty verdict someday or a plea,
a judge would decide, do you serve concurrently or
consecutively different charges? And as you might
know, if you get seven years on four different
charges consecutively, that's 28 years. If they're
concurrent, it's seven years total. So just all
of the different details that we're going to be.